former South African par Olympic Athlete
Oscar Pistorius has been released from
prison on parole he served 9 years in
prison for murdering his girlfriend
Rasin camp now under the terms of his
parole he will not be allowed to leave
Petoria women's rights groups have
protested against his release peda has
more from outside the prison in
Petoria Oscar Pistorius became eligible
for parole after serving at least half
of the 1 year sentence he was given for
the murder of rer stin Camp he was
initially uh imprisoned for 5 years for
manslaughter that was appealed and then
that sentence later extended now River
steam's family has said that while they
have faced the reality of Oscar
Pistorius uh receiving parole for some
time they have routinely opposed that
application uh they also say that they
don't believe that justice has been
served that the people who are
essentially facing a lifelong sentence
is rastin Cam's family as they continue
to mourn their daughter they say they
don't believe that he told the truth uh
around events um during the night of her
murder and that he's not remorseful and
uh that he had lied but they say they've
also taken some comfort in the fact that
during this parole period which will
last until 2029 uh that's until the end
of his sentence that you will have to
enroll in program that deal with
violence against women as well as anger
management fam Miller Al jazer ptor